sage rendent leur verdict est valide ou
non les dispositions de la loi sanitaire
celle qui a le plus fait polémique le
passé ni terre les juges
constitutionnels estime qu'il résulte
d'une conciliation équilibré entre
libertés publiques et protection de la
santé
le pass devrait donc entrer en vigueur
dès lundi on en parle tout de suite avec
à notre reporter david khalifa bonjour
aux avis dès lors vous êtes à port royal
là où sont rassemblés les manifestants
et le pasa knitter vais le dire a été
validée par le conseil constitutionnel
on imagine beaucoup de déception il ya
des signes
oui amira de la déception et surtout de
la colère pour la plupart des
manifestants venus en petit nombre
ici encadrés par un important dispositif
de sécurité est disproportionné par
rapport au nombre de manifestants
présents à port royal pour se diriger
ensuite vers le conseil constitutionnel
avant qu afin de protester contre cette
décision a dû conseil constitionnel et
constitutionnelles cet après midi à une
première réaction avec moi à la réaction
de jérôme rodrigues une des figures de
kouandé gilet jaune jérôme bordellès
merci de répondre à nos questions on
imagine beaucoup de tristesse mais aussi
beaucoup de colère et finalement c'est
pas tellement une surprise en cette
validation du conseil considère constat
qu'on sait qu'on soutienne pas je
t'avouerai franchement qu'on a
énormément de deux camarades là qui ont
pris une sacrée casquette parce que je
pense qu'ils avaient l'espoir
je crois que même l'espoir le
gouvernement l'a ruiné aujourd'hui moi
je m'attendais à ce genre de résultat
quelques fioritures sur quelques
amendements qui vont pas nous nous être
vraiment utile et le reste est vraiment
le reste est vraiment passé comme
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants donc moi je m'attendais pas à
autre chose que cette réalité on est
dans la continuité du combat ne serais
content de gilet jaune ça fait déjà deux
ans et demi qu'on est dans la rue qu'on
se bat contre plusieurs lois
liberticides déjà mises en place
donc on continuera à se battre
continuons à faire entendre notre voix
et essayer de faire en sorte que ces
lois
cette loi ne soit pas promulguée déjà
dans un premier temps avant qu'elle soit
mise en place et de continuer à la
combattre parce qu'on a quand même des
tests de juridique qui nous permette
d'aller à l'encontre comme des lois
contre la discrimination vis-à-vis de la
santé ou autres qui
n'ont pas lieu d'être a pour nous faire
biais d'un travail ou autre chose quoi
la prochaine étape du coup est ce qu'on
imagine samedi une immense mobilisation
une nouvelle fois et puis surtout une
rentrée sous le signe de la de la
révolte pour pour vous si loin que ça
c'est particulier on est quand même en
plein été
lala l'émulation est quand même assez
forte et assez mais je m'en suis encore
beaucoup de gens qui sont encore aux
vacances ils n'ont pas complètement la
réalité de ce qui est en train de se
passer aujourd'hui en france et quand on
va arriver en septembre et qui vont voir
la réalité du terrain et qui sera
beaucoup plus compliqué aujourd'hui
d'inscrire un gamin au foot de l'emmener
au cinéma ou de pouvoir participer à
loisir parce qu'on sera bloquée ne parle
pas de sanitaires là on sera secondes du
concret et les gens vont peut-être
comprendre qu'il ya un réel problème là
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué je pense
qu'ils ont choisi le bon moment pour
faire passer leurs lois les gens sont
dans la suze science des des vacances
d'été
quand ils vont revenir à la réalité je
pense que ça va être beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus probants aujourd'hui ce
qui est regrettable c'est qu'on n'a
aucune force d'opposition concrètes qui
puissent aller à l'encontre de son
gouvernement
hormis des citoyens tu sais il ya neuf
sages la plupart sont nommés par macro
ou par d'autres présidents type le sénat
où l'assemblée on partait pas gagnant
encore des hommes politiques qui
décident pour des citoyens
où sont les citoyens dans cette prise de
décision qui laisse impactent
directement dans leur vie on les voit
pas et c'est ça qui est regrettable
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup jérôme
d'avoir répondu à nos questions alors je
le rappelle que le pass à mutare est
validée dans les grandes lignes par le
conseil constitutionnel sont censurés la
rupture anticipée d'un cdd ou intérim
faute de passes sanitaires les
dispositions relatives à l' isolement
obligatoire des personnes diagnostiquées
positive aux copies de l'a19 les sages
estiment que visuellement de dix
journées nice
si nécessaire adaptées et proportionnées
d'autre part le pasteur sera obligatoire
pour accéder à certains centres
commerciaux concernant les hôpitaux le
conseil constitutionnel valide
l'obligation du passé militaire pour les
visiteurs où les passions non urgents
dans l établissement de santé maisons de
retraite tant que ce dernier ne fait pas
obstacle à l'accès aux soins et puis
comme attendu est bien le pass and i ter
sera nécessaire pour accéder au bar au
restaurant de s'asseoir en terrasse ou
alors l'intérieur merci david pour
toutes ces précisions